what's going on reject nation cobra kai
season three episode nine excited to
check this out
subscribe click that notification bell
to get notified when our reaction to the
finale
is up here on youtubes and then also hit
that like button helps with the
algorithm a lot
gotta give a major thank you to everyone
who has been following us over at our
patreon page i've been plugging this at
the top of every one of these videos
the reason why because a lot of times
these videos take a while to edit
yet we never know which ones will be
monetized and which ones will not be so
for the ones that haven't been monetized
everyone's been showing their support
our patreon has helped supplement a lot
of that loss
so thank you guys so much for following
us over at our patreon
page if you guys haven't been able to
that's a-okay
i do want to give a special thank you to
everyone who has been able to follow us
over at our patreon
anywho guys let's swing into action
handle some business
they're my grandchildren oh honey
it's good to be back in the valley well
i don't know i love this now i'm
planning to
get together with any of the old gang
while you're back that was really
unexpected
i was like who is this
what are the plans what it changed the
title no
no christmas okay she cannot interfere
with
no david i forgot about ali
last night was yeah
it was boring
[Laughter]
the kitchen i don't have much in the
fridge you're my son's teacher
i'm not sure how this works also a
neighbor that's true feeling the same
not like snow and again you're pretty
hot
so are you thanks oh show them
show her your 80s pictures what's the
matter sensing oh do you like to be
called sensei in bed
oh probably
i'm working late tonight covering for a
friend
oh you get dressed so fast man
elizabeth's shoe really kept that [ __ ]
hush-hush on
yeah sure she's back it's like a
shoe-assance these days
hey johnny sorry it took me so long to
write back things have been crazy over
here
don't know johnny don't mess this up man
okay it's just a lunch
he liked all her photos every single one
so she had plans miyagi taught karate
the right way focusing on defense
yeah sometimes the best defense in my
office oh only four people wrote this
episode
over i never see eye to eye with my dad
i think it's the other day
use it you can own hand drum
what does it do what you scared you're
gonna get beat by a girl
all right and then
just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
ah crap i was you living there too
this is called the cobra strike okay two
moves
the lunge and the bike what the hell are
you doing here
oh what's up
we don't need him he put miguel in the
hospital
he's the enemy oh this is looking like a
cosmic oh
damn here it comes the enemy of your
enemy
is your friend so tyrone magnus
yep exactly plus you're running away
that worked out well for you last time
make out sensei grace taught me that
if you take all that hate and you
channel it
you too can have an anger issue much of
us are getting together after class
you should come is hawk going to be okay
with that
i'll have the vegan mung doll ball with
spicy oh my god he's going to meet up
with her
he's remembering his order vegan
doll bowl she's gonna get like a
cheeseburger or something
man she still looks great yeah hey hey
that's so real you look amazing
oh thank you so do you everyone's like
so complimentary towards johnny
the last time we saw each other
physicality after the um
oh yeah after that
yeah it's still raw
i'll have the uh vegan mung doll bowl
with spiced
turmeric cauliflower and coconut yogurt
how's the cheeseburger
you call it you got it exactly right
it's the only way that we get johnny
lawrence ordering something
is if it was a joke it said exactly the
cheeseburger
i'm the tv king if you're gonna bring
boys over to the dojo
leave the door open come on dad it's not
1984.
what happened in 1984 big brother george
orwell surveillance
you're a roll john
episode nine baby and just imagine if
robbie newman
was back in the picture yeah just
imagine sam really
it happened last night and we just
stopped giving a [ __ ]
he's a good person he's not cobra kai's
number one bully he's not even in cobra
kai anymore
he's an eagle fan right yeah
way better he's okay i'm good
it's warm though no i just don't need a
drink to pretend to be cool
oh ho ho ho ho ho i gotta say that
robbie's so
cool i really love him this season man
especially with his new do
you resort to peer pressure that's kind
of my thing
resorting to peer pressure it's all
about that peer pressure
cobra kai
are you going to beat up little kids
you'll see come on
no pay for the animals yeah what are
they doing i just can't believe our
first date was going so badly
well our second date went much better
memory lane man those are good times
i cannot believe that you are sensei
yeah well like after high school did
pretty good i'm so happy for you
actually that's [ __ ]
really you say this girl i was dating
got pregnant i didn't know the first
thing about being a dad
oh wow she's being very vulnerable
eventually i screwed everything up
season four is gonna have a real
therapist
you have everything amazing career
beautiful family ally the good doctor
ali the good mom ali the good wife two
of those are real shows
ex-wife ex-wife greg and i are separated
[ __ ]
is actually a great guy he's an idiot i
don't like this
you better think about what you did
about me
i love after all these years you can
still make me laugh surprise she doesn't
want me with danny
yeah look i screwed up back in the day
i took you for granted it was high
school man yeah you did mess up my radio
didn't you
you ran over it with your motorcycle she
sounds turned on that's right
i do remember punching you in the face
though that was fun yeah i had that
yes you did yeah mean right hook you
want to join eagle thing
i want to do something really fun
she's a beaut huh let's go visit danny
larussa
the both of us together when i first
moved out here my mom and i didn't have
two pennies to rub together
originally from jersey right i think so
yeah he lived up in the hills he didn't
know that i'm sure he must have told you
all about our time back in high school
he did you were a bully daddy what else
did johnny tell you
let me confuse you
[Laughter]
we're getting a little gift presenting
it's got to be an eagle or something oh
it's birds no it's cobra
sorry that bird's a prey sign boy
you guys are so stupid you didn't bring
the one thing you were in charge of i
forgot okay i've got a lot of my mind
right now get in there robbie if i don't
pass the trick this semester my dad's
gonna [ __ ] in my mouth
i'm not gonna stick my hand in there hey
who's in there
oh no robbie get the snake robbie he's
going to come out as a necklace
[Music]
you're my best friend man you're the
best out of all of us
this here clinches it year clinches it
you're better than hawk everyone know
this
what about halloween the water hose the
water hose was the least of it believe
me
and it was just sitting there it was
so teed up trust me i think sensei was
just upset because ali was his first
love no
she was mine too there's just something
about her
i think she looks better now she's aged
extraordinarily
guys it's a different time things are a
lot more open now
ally was the start of all this sam
yeah okay do me a favor just put the
cover back on the car i'm done vetting
your boyfriend
keep the sparring to a minimum
understood yes sir
only finish on her face
you get him to sit down with your sensei
and talk about it with you and solve a
lot of our problems
i don't see that happening i think the
show's been hinting a lot at it
hey good old golfing stuff
no way they're they're back dude you
just you just slept with miguel's mommy
oh was this her plan i don't know but it
kind of seems as though she
was at least like hoping she seemed to
have something kind of malevolent about
when she talked to her mom
yeah oh i have a plan
ah i swear you really don't have to win
that many tickets to get good stuff
yeah where is this version of the valley
for us
oh i think this place is in ventura oh
great this is gonna go online
oh no then it's going to get tagged
yeah i want to know more about robbie
i don't know he's just got a juvenile
yeah i miss him why are you not here
greg hasn't [ __ ] greg it's actually
my first christmas alone
oh no yeah i think they're more upset
about the divorce than i am
they're sitting so close to each other
god no guys stop drawing the tension out
johnny you've been learning all season
to do the right thing
all season to do the right thing get it
it might be the kids
what is it oh i promised my mom i would
go to this stupid party
do you want to come do you want to come
save me from the boredom you sure oh
yeah i'm sure
oh she is she's all about this
admittedly a lot of fun
well done she goes from one blond hair
blue eye white guy in a tv show to
another blue
[Laughter]
good job oh
hawk is simmering you see what you can
accomplish when you work together
[Music]
they helped save your valley they gave
quite a speech
uh they make a pretty good team ah well
it's getting
dismissed oh crazy clever [ __ ] man
he's
clever so clever
that kid's still alive can we at least
put on a christmas special
i'd even watch that creepy one with a
little elf
dentist what's wrong with this picture
oh he's making it happen this isn't a
keg party
bought this hat with nothing you
parent trapped us ah this is the start
of it all guys yes
cobra kai is the bigger threat now the
enemy of my
enemy is my friend
everyone's learning from crease mcgill's
all for it
i know we've all done shitty things to
each other yeah like break your mixes on
god i hate your stupid face so much if
you died i wouldn't even attend your
funeral
i want those two to go head to head
oh no
johnny stop it honey
i'm so conflicted right now the fighting
will never end
it just keeps getting worse i can't
believe this is happening
oh that was good
what an ending is that even the actual
ending just a few more minutes and that
could have been a season finale all
right
it's okay they're going to drag that
last minute out to 40.
god damn oh god damn oh
it's so so smart the way they write this
shows
man like all that stuff with ali that
she comes back in it
is if you think about when he first
emailed her there was nothing happening
between him and miguel's mom
there's nothing happening so you're like
oh we should come back in the show will
they strike up the romance danny's
married and amanda is a cool
character you don't have to worry about
that being a threat let's just have
her come back in the show when they
strike up a romance again and of course
they bring her
back to create some tension here some
conflict
in more ways than one because i'm
sitting here going well okay look i know
they're not an established relationship
but they've been they've been having a
romance going between miguel's mom and i
gotta learn freaking
mcdonald's mom and and johnny
this episode starts off the morning
after they've slept together so you know
they've got some romantic tingling here
and then of course
meeting up with ali and i like i get the
temptation johnny
i i get it she's got a real fun
personality their personalities seem to
mesh well in a lot of ways with kind of
her you know wanting to have more
fun rebellious attitude that like that
glimmer that smile that she has or you
just see this part of sight in her
that's like oh i want to just have a fun
time a wild time and then of course the
nostalgic factor and the and the factor
of him
feeling guilt over the past moments
they've had and wanting to make things
right and rekindle that so i
get it at the same time though i'm like
but dude
this is not just some woman who miguel's
mom is it's miguel's mom she's your
neighbor
mom this is there's so much so much
riding on that you know she doesn't live
here right like she just lives in
colorado like she's visiting
so this is a tough situation chance for
johnny to clean up bro
get two in one day i'm just saying like
what started off with possibly bringing
ally back into the show as like a
romantic hook for the audience a
nostalgic element for the audience
again this just goes back into what i
think this series does so well with not
just doing nostalgia characters or
nostalgia elements but
having to drive the plot forward and
creating stakes
because now with the personal life
things of it there's so much on the line
if he does stuff with her and then
miguel's mom finds out you know
or like what that does to his character
because he seems to not give two shits
well yeah because he's he's so wrapped
up in the whole
just in her aura and her gravitational
pull and i mean i i do
feel that extra ounce of like she is the
one that got away
so i feel like that could cause you know
just like
years and years or years of time away
and growth just to disappear
and it's funny because yeah i mean like
i've been sitting here waiting for her
to show up and like ah i'm gonna be so
excited when ali shows up because you
know it's cool to see elizabeth's shoe
back but then
i didn't expect that that would be the
most tense aspect of this like yeah
watching the two of them together it was
funny because simultaneously i kept
having the warm and fuzzies and the
complete dress
because like they do have such good
chemistry and i could see how they
could maybe work but also yeah like
we've had such a long game with miguel's
mama it's such an
organic thing that they have unfold
there i mean
like yeah i don't feel the warm and
fuzzy but that has nothing to do with me
not liking ally like i like ally yeah
she's charming she's sexy she's all
these good qualities
and you feel the chemistry between them
it's really just the uncomfortableness
of the situation
of like dude you just slept with me
this morning it was this morning you're
about to kiss another woman a few hours
later
like this is not good dude and i think
the way they just toy with the audience
on that i just think it's brilliant
writing
utilizing that flashback again not just
for nostalgic purposes but for
solid writing purposes of how yes when
danny is talking with miguel
you're flashing back to moments of
karate kid one about ali how this all
started with ali the rivalry between
them
but then when johnny is reminded of when
things really went wrong between him and
ally uh like the last time he saw her
was when johnny
lost and then she was cheering for danny
like that resentment and jealousy just
grew even stronger then so for him to
show up at this party
one that seems likely that danny would
be at some like business thingy or
whatever
some country club party he's already in
that fragile vulnerable traumatized
state
so then to have danny be there it just
brings it out of them and this and i
love that
how it's the students who are trying to
make things right and brings you back to
last episode
of look we're the ones competing we're
the ones who are fighting it's not these
adults who are causing the problems
like we're the kids and the kids are
trying to make things right now by
teaming up eagle fang and miyagi doe and
it's the adults who are making it
problematic
yeah exactly and i mean that stuff was
great too i mean like this episode
seemed like it really
focused up mostly on johnny and uh and
danny to a lesser extent with miguel and
everything but yeah i like the kids
stuff too i mean probably in the season
finale there's gonna be some kind of
big you know cobra kai versus the newly
fused
miyagi claw or whatever they're gonna
call it yeah i mean like the whole thing
where they break
into the zoo and everything and seeing
robbie go down that path it's funny to
listen to like johnny talk about him as
these things are happening in the
background
because you know he's clearly being
ingratiated into cobra kai now
this whole thing with hawk is now
beginning to be a little too obvious i
don't know if they're going down a
redemption arc or
what with him at this point rogue and
start his own
yeah i don't know what before school i
don't know what they're doing with hawk
because i'm like well if you
went away from cobra kai i feel like it
would just be out of bitterness at this
point
for them favoring robbie i mean because
robbie he got the snake
cool and they're like immediately
discovered guy kids are so
they're so fickle all right
even though we were like messing with
you the second you showed up it's been
like 20 minutes later
we're good but crease and the way how
he's using
everything to manipulate so clever on
his end
because he was out there with the town
hall meeting he was there
and to use that as oh yeah they're
teaming up yeah
he doesn't even know they're teaming up
he doesn't even know that but he was
just using that information alone was
enough to convince them and it does seem
like the other they must be working
together and teaming up
and then playing on everything that
robbie already feels towards them
playing on the whole thing that tory
fell towards me
like and and sam you're just like
uniting
their hatred together it's like a big
hatred triangle
oh so it's smart it's really good
writing it's like
really good writing yeah yeah really
clever and for the most part it feels
really natural yeah just the way that
these moments
jive up against each other in the way
that it brings these these feelings out
and whatnot i mean like yeah i agree
with with hawk it seems like the writing
has been on the wall the past couple of
episodes he's clearly
losing his out his grip on alpha status
at the very least and so
i wonder if maybe you know i mean it's
it's the next episode the last one for
the season so any like hawk redemption
arc i would expect for maybe a season
four but it still seems like that yeah
there would need to be something else
to like truly communicate something to
him
beyond just i'm not number one anymore
yeah
because it seems like if he were to
break away from them in that state yeah
i don't know exactly where he would
go i think the scenes between miguel and
johnny were really cool too because it
didn't turn into
johnny's wrong like it wasn't about that
yeah just about getting a different
perspective and a real
sincere way of talking with one another
it wasn't to the point where miguel was
like i don't know if i should trust
sensei johnny
you know anything like that he's just
getting a difference of perspective and
he knows johnny well enough to know
that johnny would probably like tweak
his story a little bit
or just come from his own selfish
perspective and not see the other side
so
well yeah his experiences alone have to
kind of you know have him
aware that there are more than one
side's thing involving karate
yeah and so the way how it came to this
conclusion with the students deciding to
work together i thought was great
but yeah elizabeth chu being back she is
she is
so good at this at this type of like
alluring
role like the her whole purpose is to be
like temptation at this point and she's
so good at playing it in such a natural
way not in like an obvious way but
i mean even like watching her work in
the boys when she decides to be like
sexual temptation alluring type of
character like she's so good at that
she's america's old flame she really
isn't she
she does a wonderful job here as well
you're like i get it man
but dude this is not not the right call
not the right call
now ruin danny's marriage yeah i don't
want the next season for that
that'd be the next step and it's
interesting because you don't spend
time with johnny and ally in karate kid
like like spending time with their
romance
so it's interesting to start this off
not with elizabeth shue
and danny reuniting but getting some of
the tenderness between
johnny and her because you don't really
forget that or feel that he's just like
yeah johnny's the bad
ex-boyfriend yeah so to have it be the
starting off point with her coming back
to be with johnny i think is
really interesting absolutely and to
continue his
like contrition because i love those
threads they pulled throughout the
season too is like you know
there are hints in this episode of him
posturing to impress her
but they're much smaller and then he
gives them up right away and it gives
way to just a really great bunch of
character scenes with a
more vulnerable than i think he's been
up until this point johnny lawrence
all right guys well cobra kai do you
prefer
ally or miguel's mom
whatever her name is look if miguel's
mom wasn't in the picture i'd be gung-ho
for rally that's just
simple that's the thing if that didn't
just
happen i'd be like a hundred percent on
board but guys
subscribe click the notification bell
hit the like button last but not least
jason the dolan jason right now
is in california just got tested
he is negative so he's a-okay
so in the middle of working from 9 30
a.m
to sometimes four in the morning i'm
trying to figure out a time
to meet up with him before he flies back
to atlanta jason
i have to message you in just a few
hours from now
the day this goes up if i played my
cards right
i will have met up with you at some
point in the morning i hope i am
successful jason
yeah you guys are going to have a lovely
little brunch together you guys are
going to be just like
just like ally and and and johnny but
johnny
jason i mean should get it because he's
editor
producer for the channel kazzy reacts
putting up
a whole bunch of reactions and he knows
how much work it takes i mean all you do
is just react
no no these take a lot of time to edit
and he's been doing a couple of movie
reaction edits for her over there
those can take up to like two days to
edit so he's been working his ass off
as well jason thank you so much you
become a really really great friend of
mine someone who's incredibly reliable
so if i have to step again at four in
the morning just to
make sure i could hang out with you
and all right i guess
i mean you know all right you guys can
live in atlanta
i barely get to see it it's worth the
sacrifice maybe you can meet up and take
a nap together
not him this guy has dr swears on like
sleeps drinking energy drinks
like that jason send some that energy
our way we'll figure it out
see you buddy
[Music]